- Welcome, welcome, welcome in.
Welcome to another
edition of "Market Takes."
I know you could have
been anywhere in the world
but you're here with me
and I appreciate that.
I'm your host, Dion Rabouin,
reporter for The Wall Street Journal.
This is "Market Takes" and
this week we are taking you
through the three most
important things that you need
to look out for this week.
We've got a lot of data coming up
as we prepare for our
last week before we get
into the Federal Reserve's
FOMC meeting next week.
So I'm gonna tell you what
the three biggest reports
are gonna be this week.
First off, we've got April Consumer Credit
coming out on Wednesday.
We get mortgage rates on Thursday
and then initial jobless claims
that same day on Thursday.
Now, those aren't generally
thought of as big reports
but ahead of the Fed, ahead
of CPI, ahead of retail sales
all coming out next week.
I'm gonna tell you why
you need to watch out
for all three of those reports
and the effect they
could have on inflation.
And as we know,
that is all the Fed is
looking out for right now.
So first off, let's talk
through this April Consumer Credit Report.
Now, that usually gets
released or doesn't usually.
That gets released a
little later in the day.
It's at 3 PM on Wednesday.
March, we had a jump of $26.5 billion
and for April, we're
expecting another jump
of $21.6 billion on the increase.
Really, without context, that
doesn't mean a whole lot,
so let me throw a chart up here
on your screen so you can
just see what we're looking at
when it comes to credit card increases.
Now, as you see up there on your screen,
just a big increase and
you see that spiking number
as we get through 2021,
2022 and then 2023.
So 2023 has even risen
faster than previous years
and there is a particular data
point I wanna talk through
but just looking up here on your screen,
you can see that big defined pickup
that really outstrips
the previous increases
that we had seen in other years.
You've just seen that spike
being a little bit more vertical
than it has been
and that chart just
illustrates what we have seen
in terms of Americans
taking on credit card debt.
Now, a very interesting fact
that I haven't seen talked
about very much is for the first time
in 20 years during the
first quarter of 2023,
Americans did not reduce
credit card spending.
We have seen a consistent theme
of Americans build up a lot
of credit card spending
in the fourth quarter.
Obviously, that's holiday
time, gift giving, flying back
and forth, travel to see
family, et cetera, et cetera.
But then in the first quarter,
consistently over the past 20 years,
Americans reduce that credit card debt.
They pay it down in the
beginning of the year.
We did not see that.
And in fact, we saw Americans taking
on more credit card debt in
the first quarter of this year.
And that theme looks to have continued
into the second quarter.
Now usually, like I said,
you get your tax refund,
you pay that down.
So the things, begin,
beginning of the year, tax refund season,
those things usually go hand in hand
with a reduction in credit card debt.
This year, we have seen an increase
in credit card debt and
actually, an acceleration
of the increase in credit card debt.
This is suggesting that some households
are under strained from
these higher prices,
higher inflation and are likely relying
on credit cards to
maintain their spending.
So we have seen retail sales last month.
We saw pick up.
We've seen spending
especially on services pick up
and a lot of folks are saying, "Okay,
well, that means the
economy is healthy combined
with the jobs numbers that we've seen."
But what it likely means is a little bit
of that psychological effect
of folks are saying,
"Okay, well, I got a job.
Job may not pay enough
for me to afford all the
things that I want to,
buy the things that I
need, but I've got the job,
so let me go ahead and take
out money on this credit card.
I'll buy things on my credit
card, pay it off later."
Well, those balances
are just getting higher
and higher and higher.
Interesting fact, follow with me.
I'm gonna throw a bunch
of numbers out here
but follow along with me.
2018, credit card debt rose 4.2%.
2019, credit card debt rose
3.5% again year over year.
Right?
2020, pandemic year, credit
card debt declined by 10.9%.
Then 2021, credit card debt rose by 5.7%.
2022, credit card debt rose by 17.4%
and we are on pace in 2023.
In March, we had 17.9%.
In April, we had 13.6%.
Now, look at this chart again.
Let's throw this chart up here
on your screen one more time
and you see that define
that very clear acceleration
in credit card debt
and we are just seeing
a huge massive pickup
and that's showing no signs of falling.
It is reversing
and defying historical norms
and just really picking up.
So that chart illustrating again
just this unusual change that we have seen
in credit card borrowing
that I think is going
along with the increase in jobs numbers
that we have seen.
That is unusual.
Usually as folks get
jobs, they got more money,
they're paying down credit card debt.
What we were seeing
instead is people taking
on more credit card debt.
We're also seeing
delinquencies rising back
to pre-pandemic levels.
So folks not being able to pay off
that credit card debt they took on.
And we know that credit
card interest rates
are at a record high, well above 20%,
by some measures, up to 24%.
So this is again, defying historical norms
and at a time when credit card debt
is the most expensive it's ever been.
Now, look, wanna talk about
another piece that plays
into that debt puzzle and
that is mortgage rates.
Now, take a look here
at the Freddie Mac mortgage rates data.
Now, we are seeing those mortgage rates
again approaching 7%.
When mortgage rates first
started picking up in 2022,
you saw home sales decline,
really dive, fall off a cliff.
But lately, we have not seen that,
even though we're seeing this up and down
in mortgage rates increasing, decreasing.
But as the 10-year
Treasury yield has risen,
it's around 3.75% right now.
You see there at the edge of
your screen on the right side,
mortgage rates starting to pick back up.
Now, that chart just
illustrates the overall trend
of mortgage rates and what
we are seeing is housing,
buyers of new homes and
existing homes starting
to pick back up again defying
even these higher rates.
So even as rates have come down
and picked back up and sort of stayed
around the same level
they were at last year,
we are not seeing consumers
turning down borrowing.
And actually, the Fed is
starting to worry about this.
We've seen Fed governor Michelle Bowman
just last week say, quote,
"While we expect lower rents
will eventually be reflected
in inflation data
as new leases make their
way into calculations,
the residential real estate
market appears to be rebounding
with home prices leveling out recently,
which has implications for
our fight to lower inflation."
That's Fed Governor Michelle
Bowman talking about,
"Hey, we think this could play
into our fight against inflation.
We wanna lower inflation,
we're keeping rates high.
That's choking off growth for businesses
but folks are taking out that
debt and on the consumer side
and credit cards and
in terms of mortgages."
So that chart is, like I said,
illustrating that folks
are not turning away
from mortgages even as
these rates move higher.
Last chart I want to talk to you about
is the initial jobless
claims and what we're seeing,
we saw this surprisingly strong
job report data on Friday
and we have seen initial jobless
claims really surprise us.
Wanna put up here a chart
on your screen now that
shows initial jobless claims.
This is not seasonally
adjusted right here.
You see that big spike at
the beginning of the year
and we've seen the numbers
kind of pick up and fall down
but you're seeing big spikes
in pickup when the data is not
seasonally adjusted, right?
You see a boom, pickup, oh,
okay, that could be worrisome.
Now I wanna put up here on your screen
the seasonally adjusted when
smoothing out that data.
Well, it looks a lot less worrisome.
You're seeing a lot lower numbers
and consistently, the trend
is much more consistently low
than it has been historically.
And again, the Fed wants
to see more jobless claims,
the Fed wants to see more folks filing
those unemployment claims
because that's gonna
slow the labor market,
that's gonna slow down the economy.
And that chart is illustrating
that we have not seen, once
the data has been smoothed out,
a big pickup in initial jobless claims,
a big pickup in folks
filing for unemployment.
And another big increase
that we got, or another change we got
that was very meaningful was
Massachusetts removed a number
of fraudulent claims from
its unemployment data
and that led us to the biggest
initial jobless claims drop
that we had seen since 2021.
Massachusetts said, quote,
"It was experiencing an increase
in fraudulent claim activities
and unadjusted claims
fell by more than 2,000."
That's big for one state
in a state that's really
not all that large.
So labor market has only
slowed down a little bit
even with 500 basis points
of Fed rate increases.
That's not a good sign for the Fed
if what they wanna do is
slow down labor market,
which we know they do
because they've said as much.
Fewer layoffs mean the Fed
rate hikes aren't working
and the labor market is not weakening,
which means, again, as we've seen,
folks are spending on those credit cards
and they're buying more things
and the inflation rate is not coming down
the way they want it to.
Listen, this all comes together
in that consumers have more jobs
so they feel more
confident in taking on debt
even if they can't buy things now.
They say, "Hey, we'll put
it on the credit card."
We're seeing declining loans from banks.
We're seeing lower personal
loans and lower loans
to businesses and we know
the economy is slowing
but consumers are still spending.
That's keeping inflation high.
Fed has a big decision to make this week.
The market is largely expecting
that they're gonna hold.
We will see what happens
at the Fed Rate Conference
and listen, that's gonna do it for us here
on "Market Takes."
I know you could have
been anywhere in the world
but you were here with
me and I appreciate that.
I'm Dion Rabouin for
The Wall Street Journal.
We will see you next time.